- MRS. WHITAKER, I HAVE
BEEN BABYSITTING FOR 20 YEARS.
I'VE SEEN IT ALL.
- THE THING IS,
FOREST IS A UNIQUE CHILD.
- EVERYTHING
IS GONNA BE FINE.
I WANT YOU TO HAVE
A GOOD TIME TONIGHT.
YOU DESERVE IT.
- OKAY, UM...
GOOD LUCK.
- THANK YOU.
[sighs]
[eerie music]
♪
- GOO-GOO GA-GA.
[heavy footsteps]
- [recoils]
HEY THERE, FOREST.
- GOO-GOO GA-GA.
I WANT...
I WANT MILK.
- YOU WANT ME TO GET YOU
YOUR BOTTLE, BUDDY?
- I WANT MILK!
- OKAY.
- THIS IS A BA-BA.
I WANT MAMA'S MILK.
WHY CAN'T I HAVE
MAMA'S MILK?
IT'S A SIMPLE REQUEST.
- WELL, YEAH, WELL, UH,
Y-YOU CAN'T HAVE MAMA'S MILK
RIGHT NOW, BUDDY.
UM, HOW ABOUT WE PLAY?
- OKAY.
I WANT...
I WANT--
I WANNA PLAY WITH MY LEGOS.
- OKAY, YEAH.
OKAY, BUDDY, LET'S, UH,
GET YOUR LEGOS THEN.
- I WANNA...
I WANNA PUT
THE SMALLEST LEGO IN MY MOUTH.
THAT'S WHAT I'M GONNA DO.
- NO, NO, NO.
YOU CAN'T--YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
- WHAT?
FIRST YOU TELL ME
I CAN'T HAVE MAMA'S MILK.
NOW I CAN'T HAVE
THE SMALLEST LEGO IN MY MOUTH?
WHAT A NIGHT.
THIS IS A BAD START.
- WAIT, BUT FOREST,
IT'S DANGEROUS.
- LET ME GET THIS STRAIGHT.
YOU'RE IN CHARGE OF ME?
IN MY HOUSE?
- ALL RIGHT, F-FOREST,
I-IT'S TIME FOR BED.
- I GUESS THEN
YOU GONNA SING ME A SONG.
- WHAT?
- MOMMA ALWAYS SINGS ME A SONG
BEFORE I GO TO SLEEP.
ARE YOU GONNA
DO THAT FOR ME?
- OKAY, OKAY.
YEAH.
YES, I WILL.
♪ HUSH, LITTLE BABY
DON'T SAY A WORD ♪
- KEEP--KEEP SINGING.
- ♪ MAMA'S GONNA
BUY YOU A MOCKINGBIRD ♪
- PUT MY NAME IN IT.
I LIKE--
I LIKE IT PERSONAL.
- ♪ HUSH, BABY FOREST WHITAKER
DON'T SAY A WORD ♪
- GOO-GOO GA-GA.
- ♪ MAMA'S GONNA
BUY YOU A MOCKINGBIRD ♪
- GOOD BABYSITTER.
- ♪ AND IF THAT MOCKINGBIRD
DON'T SING ♪
- HAVE A GOOD CRY.
- [sobbing]
♪ MAMA'S GONNA BUY YOU
♪ A DIAMOND RING